We're gonna be doing May's back test.
Honestly, you wouldn't believe the mayor I've had.
Today I've lost over four hours of recorded footage.
So I've already back tested May and June,
and the footage was corrupted.
So here I am again, back testing again.
So I'm gonna try to make it a lot faster.
Start by adding the indicator
that always seems to get corrupted.
They really need to fix that.
Honestly, I'm lots of words.
How sad I am to rerecord this
when I could be doing another two months.
But here we are.
Life is not about what happens to you.
It's about what you do.
Opportunity to be a little bit stoic.
But I would be lying if I said to you I wasn't a head loss.
I'm gonna try to get through it a little bit quicker.
The other ones were two hours each.
I'm gonna try and do them in an hour.
So just try and follow along.
We're bearish.
I'm looking for cells.
What's this?
May the first?
Okay, well London's sessions already started.
London's sessions finished.
New York session.
Check for news.
ISM, interest rate decision.
Joe.
Yeah.
I don't really wanna be trading through that.
Don't play head too fast, please.
There's no set up here.
There would be a set up here.
The issue is, do I wanna trade this close to interest rates?
I don't have jobs, but I'm gonna trade it.
I don't know if it's been, I don't remember what happens in this entire price
look.
331, so we're up 33% February, March, April, May.
Okay.
I did it again.
I did this exact thing last time.
That's my mistake, because I didn't change it to UTC minus four.
It was the exact same thing last time.
So it's actually 9.45.
AM, ESD, which means in 50 minutes it's jobs.
So of course I'm not gonna trade through that.
Can you believe I did that exact same thing in the last recording as well?
We're still bearish, so I'm looking for shorts, plain and simple.
No news, that's a sweep.
The issue here is that we're bullish, so right now we are bullish,
until we break the lows down here on the M1.
So although it looks great, we are bullish.
Thus, we can't long on M1.
Still bullish, still can't long on M1.
Bear off, come to New York session.
New York is, we're still bullish on M1.
We shift bearish when the session's finished.
London session, next day.
We are now officially bullish again.
So we'll look for long positions, below Asia session low.
That's equal lows.
And that's New York, NFP.
That takes us to Monday.
Um, our swing low is here on the M15, right?
We changed character, had a pullback, breaker structure, pullback, continuation
.
So we're bullish.
Equal lows, New York session, continuation.
Makes sure a lot of times are correct.
London session, we are still bullish.
We're already below Asia session low.
And this is where I believe we get the shift.
Yep, so now we can look at longs.
Oh, M1 is actually bullish from here.
So our M1 and M15 structure is the same.
So this goes down as just discretionary if I take it,
because I've had to use internal structure.
So just be aware of that.
So we have balance of trade, which is already finished,
and then we're clear into the temp.
So that's tagged up for 10.
And
that would be my break even.
Where's 5R?
5R would be here.
So that will go all of stops to break even.
Nice.
That's 5R.
Let's close 50% at 5R.
And
the end target is up here, which is 13R.
The next
the next logical structure break would be here.
So I'll also close partials this high.
And that's break even.
And you can see that that break even is, again,
exception risk management.
So we'll journal that.
The entire playbook gets followed.
The m1 is, we are changed characters,
so we are pro-trend.
The difference between the one before is that the m1 was bearish.
When I didn't do the shorts in here,
that's because the m1 was bullish when we're trying to short.
But here the m1 was bullish, and we're trying to long.
So it does make sense to be able to use internal structure.
So tags, setups.
This is
London.
London sweep frank, technically.
Point of interest is weak.
London trend is trending.
Structure flow is void premium discount.
Yes, news.
No news execution window.
4 to 5 a.m.
It is London sweep frank, but it's also discretion.
So next day, we've now shifted bearish, so I'm looking for shorts.
Does not break a structure.
New York opens equal highs at Asia.
They get swept, but it's out of session.
That's better.
Lovely sweep of liquidity in here.
We're still bearish when the swing highs appear.
That's a break of structure.
New York session opens with news.
That shifts us bullish.
Obviously no trading in there.
Hopefully you don't think I'm rushing it, because it's not a case of rushing it
.
Paying attention to the price action that requires attention.
The swing structure here, I already know, is the swing lows down here.
So we're looking for longs.
So that right there, that sweep of Asia low.
So technically, the M1 hasn't even shifted bullish right now.
Technically, the M1 only shifts bullish here.
It's 3.49 on a Friday.
Michigan consumer at 10.
Our swing high is up here.
A little bit of an unorthodox position, not my favorite type of trade.
The reasoning behind this is quite simple.
Number one, the trade is 2.5 risk reward, which we don't like.
That means I have to extend my target all the way up here for a one to five.
Secondly, in an ideal world, I would have liked to have put my stop loss below
this low.
I would have, it would have been much better setup if this broke here.
So this only wicks, even on the M1.
Ideally, that closed, we get tagged in here and then we trade.
But now we're having to tag in here, which is a lower probability setup.
In my opinion, price tag goes in.
We move out of that level.
Still could argue that this is unmitigated.
So instead of losing $13,000, we'll bring it down to 10 in here.
Now, okay, that becomes mitigated.
Now I would move my stop loss below this low.
This becomes mitigated and we have an expansion out of it.
Price shouldn't trade through this level.
If price trades through this level, then the reality is, is that price is most
likely to
continue trading lower because it should be, it should be respecting this
demands area,
this demand area, this demand area, and then this demand area.
If it doesn't affect this demand area, then demand is in control and we'll
likely
see this when it's liquidity.
As expected, that's a break even.
Again, impeccable management.
Do we take the lows?
Because in an ideal world, I would have liked these lows to be my lows.
We have Michigan soon.
I don't really know how to trade this.
Yeah, it's not tradable and unsurprisingly, that's quality management.
Follows all the rules.
Great risk management.
This is London, sweet, Asia. Point of interest is
anti-logue. Trend is...
Trend is...
Okay, choppy price action.
We're bearish, swing high, swing low, looking for shorts.
A structure.
So, our structure was actually like this.
And like this.
I'm skipping too far ahead again.
So, we're looking for, yeah, we're looking for shorts.
That would be short.
How would I enter the trade?
Probably M5 inverse.
There you go.
Anything on the M2, M3, M1.
Yeah, M5 inverse, there you go.
And 1 to 5 would be down here.
Obviously, we're going to have price taxes in.
And price goes.
At that point, I don't know why it's moving in one minute candles.
At that point, I would be my stops to break even.
We've come in, we've tagged, we've traded out at that level.
We've mitigated this area that needed to mitigated.
And that's a break-even compressor.
Again, you'll notice consistently with our management,
like our trade management is on point.
And I think our trade management is the thing that makes our system so good.
I'm going to check out premium discount.
Mm, we hit premium discount.
Break-even.
Why is that a three-side?
So we're still in.
Why is price running through?
Okay, there's no shift in there, as you can see.
And that takes us to New York.
Monday's the 8th of May.
No news.
New York comes in.
We've already had a sweep of liquidity.
But to shift structure.
I've seen this a lot of it broken.
Plain and simple.
Oh, I wish I'd bullish.
So now we need to see our retracement back into here.
It's a continuation, which is very unlikely.
And that's the data.
Next day, we're now bullish.
So we're looking for longs.
Strong point of interest.
Price will really struggle and to break that high.
Interesting.
That high gets a lot of respect.
How many trades go through that?
So now a valuable bet.
That's 4.4a, I'm not going to get a trade.
Let's move to New York.
So we could be looking to long.
We need to see our retracement into this London session.
London area.
I just checked you to the point.
That's my bet.
PPI, that's my bet.
I've always on 13th because I was checking Asia.
Yeah, we have news.
London session.
We are bullish.
Asia lowers our swing low.
So you know, I'm always going to avoid that.
That's a sweep.
That's a break.
This becomes our new swing low.
Also, I'm not going to try and trade from there.
For me, that just doesn't make sense.
It's also a high is up here.
So there's no opportunity to even trade.
15th of May.
We have a bunch of news.
Inflation rate, CPI.
Inflation rate, core inflation rate.
So this day is going to be a miss as well.
You're not going to trade off the back of that.
Unless you were to literally.
Try and place along here.
Didn't even do stop last below here.
You'd take profit.
Would he be here?
It's not even one to five.
That's not one to five.
And it's also just a lot more risky.
Yeah.
For London.
I wouldn't trade that.
The new swing low is now here.
So we're still bullish.
We're still looking for longs.
That could be a long set up.
Just need to check the M1 structure.
That's confirmed.
So this is a long set up.
Cool.
And then.
Pretty much a straight one's five.
And straight out.
Everything is on point.
This is a London sweep rank.
Point of interest is empty lag.
Session is obviously London.
Trend is trending.
Right.
Yes.
Structural flow is actually.
Bearish.
We're not in the premium discount.
There is no news.
As far as I'm aware.
No, no news.
Not for this session anyway.
We're building permits 830.
I don't really expect a huge move from that.
Let's not shift.
And that's the session over.
New York.
Same bias.
I'm looking for longs.
That's building permits.
No shift there.
Maybe one there.
Nope.
That could be.
But it isn't.
And the session done.
Next day.
Would love to see these lows get taken.
This is a much higher quality set up for me.
We have obviously.
This entire area really is an area of interest,
but we have a really nice point of interest down here.
We have equal lows down here,
Asia and previous days, New York.
That's actually an A+ set up for me.
That's the session over.
Here's New York.
We have Fed, Powell.
Oh, no, that's on the 19th.
So we have no news.
This is an A+ set up to me.
But that doesn't count.
I need to see price break.
This high.
For break this high then.
To break on the M1.
Although it's not a clean break.
It's a break.
Yeah, M15 and 30.
I'll go with this as my entry.
No.
Stopped at the lows.
Swing highs.
Place order.
But I have multiple take profit levels here
that I can already see.
First take profit level is obviously 5R.
Second take profit level will be these equal highs.
Good expectation of those being taken out.
Third take profit level would be these highs.
And then fourth take profit level will be here.
Bear in mind though, it is a Friday.
Many of you guys probably can't hold your trade over the weekend.
I personally also don't really like to hold positions over the weekend,
especially with prop firms.
So be cautious of that.
That's a tag at 8.10.
We don't have any news.
So that becomes an opportunity to get to break even,
but this is still unmitigated for me.
So I would move my stops under these lows.
So at least I've gone from $13,000 risk to $3,000 risk.
So I've cut off a significant amount of my risk there.
That's 5R.
So we'll close 50%.
We'll move our next take profit level up to here.
That's another take profit level.
We're going to close 50% of the remaining position.
So half of the half, right.
And then we have another take profit level up here.
So we're going to expand towards.
That's also going to take another 50% of the remaining position.
So we're closing half of the open position each time for a higher average
reward.
And then the final target is up here.
And now we'll see how much of the development we get.
But the real move that I wanted to catch is this from here,
in here to here.
This for me is an A plus setup, right?
Again, for setups like this, there's no set tags.
But what you can do is you can organize your data yourself.
You can go in just like we're using the journal stuff and whatnot ourselves.
You can start to get, you can start to customize your own tags, right?
So for example, you can have one section where you have kind of your personal
opinion, right?
Which is either this is an A plus setup.
It's a low quality setup, you know, your opinion, your subjective opinion.
And then when you're about to take a trade, you can start noting that down in
this area here.
So reasons, you know, x, y, z for this specific setup.
It's an A plus setup.
It's not an A plus setup.
And then tag it accordingly.
And then again, at the end, it's all about data analysis.
At the end, when you've got your data, you're going for all of your data,
then you can begin to start making things make sense.
Pretty simple.
You can start understanding.
Okay, I said this was an A plus setup.
And I noticed that actually the setups that I say are A plus,
there's a 60% memory on those setups.
And now I can kind of, you know, objectify those setups by the characteristics
that I've set out for for those.
I can see low probability setups before they happen.
And I noticed that the low probability setups,
they should have a 30% win rate, right?
But they're still profitable.
So maybe I go in there and try to understand some of the characteristics.
And this is where you get all deep into your data analysis,
because it's the work of building an edge isn't in the concept.
It's not the fancy liquidity sweeps and order blocks and market structure
shifts
and all the fancy jargon.
The real edge building process is in the data refinements.
It's in the organization of your data
and refining the database of characteristics.
That's where edges are built.
Few, few understand this.
Everyone's looking for a secret strategy.
But the real secret is how to build a strategy.
And that's my entire purpose.
Like what I'm trying to do is show you how to do that.
Not just give you an edge.
Not, you know, just give you a step-by-step strategy.
Obviously I want to do that because I need to prove to you,
number one, that the edge works.
That you have an edge to start with.
But my main thesis on my main goal and the purpose of this program
isn't to just give you a trading strategy and hope for the best for you.
Because I know that I can give a million people the same trading strategy
and very few of them will ever achieve success.
Because it's not about the strategy.
It's about the trader becoming a trader.
And this is one of the biggest parts of the common trader.
It's understanding how to back test, how to collect data,
how to organize data, how to tag all of this sort of stuff.
This is the real work of a trader.
Period.
No magic system will save anyone.
Let's see, it's 2 p.m.
I want to close this trade at market close.
So that's the market close.
So you have two options here.
Number one, you can hold the position over the weekend.
You know, there's this is 6R profit right now.
You can close it.
Or you can hold it in hopes that next week we expand up to here and get 12R.
You'll be able to double up.
For me, personally, holding the trade over the weekend.
Enduring the extra fees or the problems that might incur if you have a problem.
Just to double the open profit right now doesn't really align for me.
Holding it over a couple of days.
Sure.
But over a weekend, I don't really see the point.
I'm just much better off closing the position.
That's how I would treat my actual trade.
So we're going to close the rest of that at 6R, which means we've closed half
at 5R.
We closed basically another half, but 6.5R.
No.
We've got like 30% at 6R and then something close like 20% at AR.
Something along those lines.
25% and 12.5% and 12.5% and 12% yeah.
Cool.
Let's go to the next day.
So again, prices continue trading high.
And again, that's just something that you have to kind of bear the consequences
of
plain and simple.
We're still bullish.
I'm still looking for longs.
I'd rather come in with a fresh, clean slate.
That's equal lows.
That's lower prices.
New York session.
Monday, 20th of May.
Do we have any news?
No, we don't.
So I'm looking for longs.
Plain and simple.
Need to see a lower time frame shift.
That might be it.
That could be the lower time frame shift.
Let me check my structure.
100% and yeah, that would be my lower time frame shift.
And so that would pretty much be time is it 9.15.
That would pretty much be my opportunity to execute.
The problem is I'm not a huge fan of the price action.
I mean, there just isn't really anything.
You could just use this.
Could just use this 30 minute level.
Could use that.
But there's nothing clear on the M1 or M5.
Again, even that's like 3.9 R.
So your entire take profit level has to come up here.
Because I'm looking at it like this.
I broke the high.
We have an order block, price mitigates it.
We'll create a new order block.
Trade out, price mitigates it.
But then there's also the problem of like, okay, cool.
This is where this is the type of stuff
that used to get me in trouble a few years ago
where I tried to over refine things.
Like, okay, cool, well, everything's been mitigated.
So can't I just take that right?
And that's this type of behavior that will get me in trouble.
And it might work for one trade.
But I don't care about one trade.
I care about hundreds of trades.
So we'll, I don't know really how to execute it to benefit you.
We can execute from here.
Because it's not a problem that's not something to execute.
We can get away with doing something like that.
But if I want to get into those habits,
not really.
Okay.
Let's try this.
And no tag.
We end up not getting tagged.
If we got tagged, we could be comfortably breaking them right now.
But sometimes that's how it's going to go as well in real life.
The reality is that I don't understand why we didn't get tagged.
If my order was here and price traded back into that level.
Oh, that's because I moved it to here.
Sometimes that's how it's going to go in the live market as well.
It's not like an able to set up anyway.
But yeah, how does it play out?
That's our original entry.
And price going to equal lows.
Price going to trade lower anyway.
So it would have been a break even anyway.
As expected.
We get rid of that.
That's no longer relevant.
We're still bullish.
We're literally still bullish.
So we're still looking for longs.
No longs in here.
Tuesday 21st.
No news.
New York session.
Wow.
Does that take out the swing lows?
No.
Can we trade that?
I don't know.
One time is that line 30.
I mean, we could try.
We could try trading.
Try trading is kind of invert.
There you go.
Price trades there as trading lower.
What's the rest of the reward?
One to five.
Nine 30.
Price taxes in.
Gonna move my stop here.
Let's see.
We're out of ours.
Expansion pullback.
That's my break even point.
This entire has been mitigated.
Although there's a small area that's unmitigated,
but the overall area itself has been mitigated.
That's the area.
That's our break even.
And again, even at this point,
when price tags me comes back to this area
and begins trading higher,
I'm going to move my stop anyway below this low,
which is exactly break even.
So I don't really care.
But let's see management pay us on our...
No, sometimes that's how it goes.
We're still looking for longs.
Um, this is a weird one,
because Asia's session lower has been taken.
We're looking for longs.
We're bullish.
Where's our structure?
So our swing lowers down here.
Swing highs up here.
So we're still...
We're still need to see this just for London to shift bullish.
This high will need to be taken.
Failure to take the high.
Still technically bullish on the M1.
That may be a shifting bearish.
And there's the low that goes anyway,
which says that this was good management.
But that's that New York 22nd FOMC.
That's two.
Where's our structure like right now?
Okay, let's see what New York gives.
And that's us bearish.
If we bearish right now,
we're not going to get anything from this session.
Nope.
That's a bearish continuation.
It's technically bullish.
That's also technically bullish.
So I say it's 23rd.
H comma 3.
So it makes sense.
I don't really know how to trade that,
but to be honest with you.
There's nothing in there.
And now we're bearish again.
So we're bearish.
We're looking for shorts.
There's not a shift in there just to be clear.
Is there?
Nope.
Almost.
But nope.
Okay.
It's not a shift there.
There's no M1 shift there just to be clear.
You can see.
I can read the M1 on the M15 pretty well.
New York session.
24th on a Friday.
We have durable goods at 8.30.
So I want to be cautious of that.
I want to be trading until that durable goods comes out.
That's durable goods.
We could look at trading now though.
If we can get a shift.
That shift.
I mean technically yeah.
I don't like the liquidity above the highs.
Again, this way you can kind of get creative with your
your organization of data as well.
It's like
you can start adding tags like,
hey, this isn't an A+ setup because of X, Y, and Z.
And then start adding notes.
And then at the end of all your tests, then you come back and you look all your
data.
And then you start to learn things.
That's literally how you learn.
Look at this M5.
It stops in these highs.
Don't like the liquidity above like the area of interest.
Time is it.
And 45, about 15 minutes.
And that's that.
Let's go to London.
Still bearish.
It's the last one high up here.
And let's see everyone of these Asia highs.
Equal highs.
That's a sweep.
That's a shift.
Give me one second.
Let's have a look.
What about the M1 structure?
No.
So the M1 structure is bearish.
The M1 structure is bearish.
But the swing low.
We break down here.
Impossible to read this.
This is basically the swing low.
And this is the swing high.
So we bearish.
We could look at internal structure.
But even the internal structure.
For the internal to shift bearish, we have to break down this low.
We can break down as well.
We should count.
If we break this high, we become entirely bullish.
And that's the session done.
And okay, now we're bullish.
Okay, now we're bullish.
New York session is a little bit weird price action to be honest with you.
It's Monday.
It's Monday, the 27th.
There's not really a way to trade this price action.
Because there's no target.
The target would be here.
But there's no, unless we sweep London lows like that.
And we get a shift.
There's no shift in there.
I can tell you right now.
There's no, there's no trade there.
You can see it.
We continue trading higher.
There was no trade in here.
So we're bullish again.
And now we're bullish again.
28th of May.
There's no news.
If we can pull back into this area here, we can look for longs.
Like that.
If we can have a lower time frame shift,
the M1 is the same as the M15.
So it'd have to be internal.
So now a break.
And that's a change of character.
So now we're bullish again.
945, we're not going to get a trade.
So we go to
Tuesday, it's going to Wednesday through 9th of May.
We have GFK and we have inflation rate at eight.
We're shifted bearish.
Swing high.
That's a technical pullback.
Although I don't like it.
It's also a technical pullback that I would never trade.
That would be me using my discretion.
Is that going to break lower?
So this is technically the swing high.
I would never use this.
I would also argue that I would never use this.
So this is where my discretion would come in.
I definitely wouldn't use this in an ideal world.
So if we do end up.
If we do end up trading above these highs and trading lower,
and I take the trade, it'll be discretion.
If we break and close above this high,
it's a change of character by definition,
but I would never consider that a change of character.
So I also want to give you that element.
This is a sweep of this high,
which still technically counts towards the model.
Even if we closed above this and still got a trade,
I would still trade it.
But I would just have to mark it as discretion.
Because for me, Asia High is never a swing high.
I don't care.
But if it doesn't break it, we're still bearish.
So that's a plus.
This is also, in theory, a really strong point of interest.
Can we get confirmation?
We need to see this level, get traded through.
I'll trade it through, right?
Very minor change of character, which isn't ideal.
I prefer seeing price trade directly through.
We've broken this low.
Close below it.
You can see there, we've closed below the low.
But we immediately start our version.
We'll take it.
This is, in general, somewhat of a weird setup.
In the sense that we've swept the swing high,
but this still is a good quality setup
for the fact that we've swept Asia High.
The problem is, is there was...
Where can I trade from here, actually?
Maybe I used this M15.
Point of interest, or was it like in the five minute?
So, there's a change of character.
We have an invert to have all your gap here.
All right, this bullish all your gap has been traded through.
If we use that,
four pips, also constitutes the same area of interest
as the M15, which is ideal.
I like that.
But the risk to reward.
That's a 2.8 risk to reward.
We need five R.
Five R would be down here.
We do have this old low.
So, we'd have to swing a little bit for the fences,
which I don't mind doing, per se.
I like the equal lows as well down here, by the way.
This is another additional conference.
We'll run this.
We'll see what we get.
We get a tag.
Again, honestly, I'd like that to be a better break.
But change of characters, change of characters,
nonetheless.
Back into invert, have all you got?
That's our technical.
Break even point.
That's unmitigated.
We could move our stops to above this high.
So, risk was 13,000.
We can move that risk to 2300.
So, we've cut a significant amount of our risk off the table.
I don't see what price should trade above that level again.
Wait, what?
What's going on?
Wednesday to be nice.
Four, we don't have any news.
Interesting.
I mean, I'll take it.
Can't usually get moved like that, though.
The condensation.
Yeah.
Five r, what we aren't an hour long.
Almost finished.
Okay, I've made it less.
The last, the last recording of May
was two hours long.
This is a London sweep Asia.
And I've, here's the matters part, the craziest part.
I've recorded the same price action today.
And I still remember that none of it.
And until it plays out, like now I remember this,
but that tripped me out.
That's a strong point of interest.
It's a London session.
Trend is trending, actually.
Technically, there's no news.
Execution window.
Three to four a.m.
All times that four.
We get perfectly out of five r here.
That couldn't have been a bad trade.
And then back to breakeven as well.
New York, what are we looking for?
Oh, we need to wait.
We have interest rates.
That's interest rates.
And then I don't like those equalized out of me, obviously.
There's no reversal there, anyway.
Fair enough.
Um, bearish continuations.
Again, that's technically swing high.
For me, it's just like not, but sure.
I mean, technically as well.
This is also the next swing high.
Oh, no, it's not.
Never mind.
That was technically a swing high, but for me, that's void.
So, with bearish.
Again, for me, like I would prefer to short from here.
Although it's technically a change of character.
Price continued rallying into the upside, anyway.
Well, let's call it a change of character.
New York session.
30th of May, we have GDP at 8th, so I don't want to trade before that.
New York session 8th, or already?
Okay.
So, I don't really see a possibility to trade that.
Done it. Okay, well, I'll skip the next data on the session,
but you can see it doesn't take out Asian law.
So, it was never going to be a trade.
This is our swing low.
This is our swing high.
I'm not going to trade from here because, obviously, yeah.
Friday 31st of May.
Core PCE, yeah, I'm not going to trade this.
And untradable, anyway.
And that's session over.
Okay, we'll take a look at the data for May.
We'll run for it briefly because I want to get into June.
Nice.
Our win rate is up to 44%, which is a significant improvement.
To have a look, nice, 88.7 zealous core, which is good.
4.45 profit factor, that's insane.
Everything is really good.
Win percentage, obviously, could be a little bit better,
but at the end of this, we might be able to optimize it by looking at all the
detail,
the data, consistency on point.
Max drawdown is the only thing that drops us a little bit, but I mean,
since it's not a big deal at all, that's a really high profit factor.
Let's have a little look at reporting.
Let's look at setups.
So at the moment,
at the moment,
all of ourselves are profitable.
This is a little reversal.
It's been a trade.
It's probably not been a trade, that's why.
There's been one trade break even.
Every single one of us set up so far are profitable.
Our most profitable is the London Sweeps Asia, which is what I expected anyway.
And then at the end, we can also optimize these.
How about sessions?
So we can see that New York is still more profitable than London,
even though London has 24 trades and New York has nine
and New York is still more profitable.
That's crazy.
We've taken basically two losses in New York,
nine trades, two losses, seven wins.
Well, maybe not seven wins, maybe some break evens, but that's crazy data.
Two break evens, five winners,
71% win rate in New York, 13 profit factor as a wild.
That's nice.
Um, don't really care about looking at these at the moment.
It's going to here.
Let's show this by this monthly.
monthly net here now.
February plus 40k.
It won't.
Some thinkers.
Some thinkers burger, um, profitability.
Let's have a look at over here.
Let's have a look at, uh, in fact, let's go day in time.
Let's go months.
At least performing month, February, two trades.
We're sitting back just now.
Yeah.
Something's wrong here.
You can see here that February's a break even months.
I'm not sure why.
.
Hello.
What's occurred in the first of March?
I don't want it to include the first of March.
Okay, let's try this because we didn't even start in January.
Yeah, you can see like really difficult month in February.
Terrible zealous court, terrible win rate, profitable somehow from that to this
.
That's the importance of just being able to consistently stick to it.
We're, we're reflecting 50% returns and we've done February, March, April, May.
50% returns in four months.
So we're averaging over 10% of months.
I'm still in.
Okay.
Now it's accurate.
I don't know what was going on before.
Oh, this whole time I had it filled by New York session.
Okay, cool.
I won't bore you with the details too much.
We're going to get back into all of this at the end.
Anyway, let's go ahead and do our next month.
[BLANK_AUDIO]